this is where my embarrassing
story with a lot of wisdom happened
i'm not much of a tea drinker or coffee
i don't really like it much
but right behind me i had an experience
that i don't think i would
ever forget for the rest of my life and
i would want to share this experience
as much as i can on camera or off camera
as much as i can not only did i feel
embarrassed
humiliated but at the same time lessons
that i learned from it
was overwhelming so overwhelming that
i think an atheist and
maybe an ex-muslim who didn't know much
about
islam a muslim a jew
a christian whoever it may be you all
are going to benefit
now at the start of the video you saw
those three machines where i was
standing
that is exactly where it occurred
this is how the story goes one night i
was working i was tired
and usually because of that i usually
have an espresso i usually like to have
a double espresso
so i'm alert when i'm driving so i went
there and i said to myself you know what
espresso is a bit bitter i want
something a bit more
nice yeah a bit more sweet you know a
bit like latte but
i'm not latte so i went on google and i
thought what is stronger
you know other than latte so he gave me
the option of a mocha
if i pronounced that right yeah okay
because i've never had it ever in my
life
i went in went to the costa machine
because it should sponsor me by the way
but they're not
anyways so i went to the machine
and i pressed muka and i waited for my
drink to get prepared
i was waiting and my dream got prepared
and as you know in the costa machines it
tells you
preparing your drink hope you enjoy it
hot milk pouring
um hot water pouring uh vanilla shot
pouring
and then all of a sudden i saw there hot
chocolate
and i was like what the hell is going on
what's hot chocolate doing in a coffee
so i had a bit of a problem and i was
like oh for god's sake because i'm
already tired i want something i need to
go
so the drink was fill up i put it to the
side and i thought the machine's
probably not working
i went to the second machine which you
guys saw probably you can see on the
screen
press smoker again i'm waiting there
excited same thing hot milk
water blah blah blah hot chocolate again
what the hell is going on like i'm
thinking am i like half asleep
and i'm like why is it keep putting hot
chocolate in my coffee
so then i go to the guy and i say mate
your machine is not working there's two
drinks here which i don't want
so he he has a bit of an argument with
me because what do you mean my machine's
working the machines are fine they're
brand new
he goes there's nothing wrong with i go
are you like i got a bit
agitated yeah i was like are you telling
me i'm lying
like look come and look for your own
eyes and he was like no it doesn't it's
like it's your fault
i was like anyway so there was these two
guys who worked in the subway i said
some
guys brothers come and have a look at
yourself here i don't know if they were
muslim i go look i went to the machine
again i pressed my car i go look i want
moka i pressed it
let me see i said look carefully here
hot milk
water oh look what chocolate did you see
that hot chocolate i said i don't want
hot chocolate
i said to the guy i said look even your
friends saw it so they don't know
themselves either
so they're just like okay and they're
confused and they go who's gonna pay for
this other two i said
i'm not gonna pay for it i didn't ask
for this why would i pay for something i
didn't ask for so i'm like look
i'm frustrated i'm angry i don't want it
i'm like what is wrong with you guys i
said you saw it for yourself as well
i'm having a back and forth with this
guy and i'm like look forget it i'm not
paying for these drinks
i'm gonna order myself a latte i'm
paying for the latte i went and paid for
the latte i said i'm sorry
and i threw the mochas well the mocha
where is the hot chocolate
into the bin i left there the guy was
not happy with me i wasn't happy with
him because i was thinking what
what's wrong with you look it's not my
fault and you're asking me to pay for
something
that i'm not to blame how humiliating
how embarrassing and
taught me a lesson to educate myself
with what dreams just
a couple of days ago just couple of days
ago or last week
i found out how boka is made
yes there's hot chocolate in my car and
i felt embarrassed
i felt immediated my lack
of knowledge my ignorance of a matter i
didn't know i'm not
i don't drink or drink much i don't like
it because i did not know
i went there and moka one of the
ingredients of mocha
is hot chocolate now besides feeling
humiliated and embarrassed and i'm gonna
go in there now
and hopefully try to pay for those
drinks that i threw in the bin and
hopefully apologize
i learned a massive lesson brothers and
sisters and dear friends
a lot of the time in life this is
exactly what a lot of people do
when it comes to the creator muslims
ex-muslims atheists ex-christians jews
whoever you
are when it comes to the creator what is
the main thing
that is used if god exists why would
this happen
if god exists why would that happen why
did this guy why did the prophet do this
why did this do that
oh why are these questions being asked
because uh god has the picture and we
have the pixel
and it made me click it made me
understand and be like look ali
your lack of knowledge on a matter made
you
doubt free machines that are working
perfectly
made you get into an argument with a guy
and three other people
and in a bit of a way disrespect them
why because you don't know how mocha was
made and you did not did not know
because hot chocolate is an ingredient
of that
and because of your lack of knowledge
you took it out on all of those people
shame on me now obviously i did not know
i'm not to blame maybe
but what we need to learn is this
brothers and sisters in a nutshell
before we go in there
the fact that just because just because
we do not know
it does not mean just because we do not
know the wisdom
does not mean there is no wisdom just
because we do not have the knowledge
doesn't mean that there is no knowledge
the problem is within ourselves
and this was a fine example for us to
learn
that if you don't know something
sometimes what we believe in islam is
having trust in allah we will trust
anyone and anyone
if alan sugar came today and said go to
oxford street and sell banana skins you
know what you say
he's a businessman he's a billionaire he
knows what he's talking about
it doesn't make sense to me but i'll do
it allah allah the one who created the
heavens and the earth
is asking you to trust him like alibaba
may i love mercy on him i'm wrapping up
he said it took a doctor in a white suit
to tell me i'm gonna die
while allah was telling me all this time
so brothers and sisters
don't immediately embarrass yourself
like i did learn the lesson from this
to put your trust in god almighty and
just because you do not know something
doesn't mean
there is no knowledge behind it or there
is no wisdom i'm going to go in there
follow me i'm going to apologize to the
owner and hopefully pay for the drinks i
throw
through into the bin
oh
hello okay hi i came here
i came here um yeah a couple of weeks
ago
um i ordered some coffee uh the machine
gave me
the right coffee but i thought it was
the wrong one i threw in the bin
but i owe you guys uh two mokka
i owe you guys yeah so i wanna i wanna
pay for that i chose
more it was it was small yeah i don't
know if he was here but
sorry it was just a bit of a lack of
knowledge should i say
yeah two mockers yeah yeah okay not
feeling today
no few yeah thank you thank you sorry
about that
thank you i'll take the receipt please
okay guys so basically
i went in there and i thought to myself
you know what if i explain to this guy
what happened it's gonna be sorry i just
said look i owe you two coffees so
alhamdulillah
i just paid for those two inshallah may
allah forgive me
and educate me from now on i'm gonna
dedicate my life
to the coffee experience and find out
how
costa coffee makes their coffees
inshallah well coffee's in general
inshallah
so till next time promises hope you guys
enjoyed this video do not forget bro and
sisters
with the permission of allah we bring
you these videos we but we also need
your help
so please donate at the link below every
single penny you give
helps us to bring you these videos
inshallah and to help you guys with your
iman
and same uh for ourselves one inshallah
till next time
subscribe to our new channel salaam
goodbye here you go there's a receipt